Let's now go through
another example,
which will be a little
more challenging.
We're going to revisit
an old problem.
We have a coin that has
an unknown bias, Theta.
And we have a prior
distribution on this Theta.
We fix some positive
integer, n, we flip a coin
n times, that has
this unknown bias.
And we record the
number of heads.
On the basis of the number of
heads that have been observed,
we wish to estimate the
bias, Theta, of the coin.
To make things more
concrete, we're
going to assume a prior
distribution on Theta that
is uniform on the unit interval.
Now, this is a problem we
have considered before.
We have calculated the expected
value of Theta given X.
And we did find that
the expected value takes
this particular form.
Now, notice that this is
a linear function of X.
And if it turns out the
least mean squares estimator
is a linear function
of X, then we're
guaranteed, since
this is the best,
that this is also the
best within the class
of linear estimators.
So we immediately
have the conclusion
that the linear
least mean squares
estimator is this
particular function of X.
So there's not much left to do.
On the other hand,
just for practice,
let us derive this answer
directly from the formulas
that we have for the linear
least mean squares estimator,
and see whether we're going
to get the same answer.
So we want to use this formula.
And in order to apply this
formula, all that we have to do
is to calculate these expected
values, this variance,
and this covariance.
So now let's move on to this
particular calculational
exercise.
Let's start by
writing down what we
know about the random variables
involved in this problem.
About Theta, we know
that it is uniform.
And so it has a mean of
1/2 and a variance of 1/12.
About X, what we know
is the following.
If you fix the bias of
the coin, then the number
of heads you're going
to obtain in n flips
has a binomial distribution,
with parameters n and Theta.
But of course, Theta itself
is a random variable.
So for this reason, this is
a conditional distribution.
But within the
conditional universe,
we know the mean and the
variance of a binomial,
and they are as follows.
The mean of a binomial is n
times the bias of the coin.
But because we're talking
about the conditional universe,
this is a conditional
expectation.
And it's a random
variable, because it's
affected by the value of
the random variable Theta.
And similarly, for
the variance, it's
the usual formula for the
variance of a binomial,
except that now the bias
itself is a random variable.
So now let's continue with the
calculation of the quantities
that we need for the
formula for our estimator.
Let's start with the
expected value of X.
Since we know the
conditional expectation of X,
we can use the law of
iterated expectations.
The unconditional expectation
is the expected value
of the conditional expectation,
which is n times Theta.
And since the mean of Theta
is 1/2, we obtain n/2.
Let us now continue with the
calculation of the variance.
There are different ways
that we can calculate it.
One could be the law
of total variance.
But we will take the
alternative approach,
which is to use the general
formula for the variance,
that the variance is
equal to the expected
value of the square
of a random variable,
minus the square of
the expected value.
We know the expected value of X.
So all that's left
is to calculate
the expected value of X squared.
How are we going calculate it?
Well, we know the conditional
distribution of X.
So it should be
easy to calculate
the conditional
expectation of X squared
in the conditional
universe, and then
use the law of
iterated expectations
to obtain the
unconditional expectation.
So now, we need to calculate
this conditional expectation
here.
How do we do it?
The expected value of a
square of a random variable
is always equal to the variance
of that random variable
plus the square of
the expected value.
We're going to
use this property,
but we're going to use it
in the conditional universe.
So in the conditional
universe, this
is going to be equal
to the variance,
in the conditional universe,
which is n times Theta times 1
minus Theta, plus the square
of the expected value of X,
but the expected value in the
conditional universe, which
is this quantity--
n times Theta.
So we obtain another term--
n squared, Theta squared.
So now we can go back to
our previous calculation,
and right here,
the expected value
of this expression,
which is n times Theta.
And then we have some
Theta squared terms.
One is n squared.
The other is a minus n.
So we obtain plus n squared
minus n Theta squared.
The expected value
of n times Theta
is n times the expected
value of Theta, which is 1/2.
So we obtain a factor of n/2.
But then we have this
additional term here.
We need the expected
value of Theta squared.
What is it?
Well, since we know the mean
and the variance of Theta,
we can calculate the expected
value of Theta squared.
It is equal to the variance
plus the square of the mean.
And this evaluates to 1/3.
So from here, we're
going to obtain
plus n squared minus
n divided by 3.
And you can rewrite this
term in a different way
by collecting first the
n terms, n/2 minus n/3.
This gives us n/6.
And then there's
the n squared term,
which is n squared over 3.
Now that we found the
expected value of X squared,
we can go back to
this calculation.
We have n/6 plus
n squared over 3
minus the square of the
expected value of X,
which is this expression here.
So we obtain minus
n squared over 4.
1/3 minus 1/4-- that makes 1/12.
So we obtain n/6 plus
n squared over 12.
Or another way of writing this
is n times n plus 2 over 12.
And this completes
the calculation
of the variance of X.
The last quantity that's
left for us to calculate
is the covariance
of Theta with X.
We're going to calculate it
using the alternative formula
for the covariance, which is
the expectation of the product
minus the product
of the expectations.
We have the expectations,
but we do not
have the expectation
of the product.
So we need to calculate it.
Once more, it's going
to be the same trick.
We're going to
condition on Theta,
and then use the law of
iterated expectations.
So the law of
iterated expectations,
when you condition on
Theta, takes this form.
And to continue
here, we need to find
this conditional
expectation in the inside.
This conditional
expectation-- what is it?
If I give you Theta,
then you know Theta.
It is becoming now a constant.
There's nothing
random to it, so it
can be pulled outside
the expectation.
And we obtain Theta times the
conditional expectation of X.
We know what the conditional
expectation of X is.
It's n times Theta.
So from here, we obtain overall,
a term n times Theta squared.
So now we can go back here.
We have the expected value.
And the term in the
inside-- we just found it.
It's n times Theta squared.
And since the expected
value of Theta squared
is 1/3, from here,
we obtain n/3.
And now we can go back,
finally, to the calculation
of the covariance.
It's going to be n/3, minus
the expected value of Theta,
which is 1/2, times the expected
value of X, which is n/2.
So it's minus n over four.
And this evaluates to n/12.
So we have succeeded in
calculating all the quantities
that are needed in the
formula for the linear least
mean squares estimator.
We can now take those values
that we have just found
and substitute them
into this formula.
And after a little bit of
algebra and moving terms
around, everything simplifies
to this expression.
Just to verify that
this makes sense,
what is the
coefficient next to X?
It's the covariance
divided by the variance.
n/12 divided by
this expression--
this n cancels that n.
This 12 cancels that 12.
We're left with an n plus
2 in the denominator.
And indeed, the coefficient
that multiplies X
is the term n plus 2
in the denominator.
And you can similarly verify
that the constant term as well
is the correct one.
So of course, this answer is
what we had found in the past
to be the optimal,
the least mean squares
estimator of X. As we discussed
earlier, when this is linear
in X, it has to be the same as
the linear least mean squares
estimator.
So this answer is
not a surprise,
but it was an interesting
and perhaps useful
exercise to go through the
details of this calculation
to see what it
takes to figure out
the different terms
in this formula.